welcome back to roller coaster tycoon
one and last time I actually forgot to
do an outro to my video and it ended
prematurely when I was stupid so yeah
I'm gonna try to not do that again but
it I don't even know how it happens
sometimes I forget about things
basically everything in life ever but I
need to look at this ride and the main
job that I still need to do is doing the
scenery which I'm not too sure about how
I'm going to do it because for one it's
very expensive or at least it's going to
be very expensive considering the fact
that this is just a scenario and I want
to get some six flags wait not six flags
doesn't even theme the right I mean
Cedar Park ish scenery out there but not
really sure how I'm going to do that
first and foremost though I am going to
replace the textures because that's
somewhat easy and kind of cheap and
really important if you want to get your
rights to actually look decent and I
don't know if this text view is going to
be too good for this kind of case but
I'm just gonna try it you might try that
as well but no I think I'm going to use
this texture because pretty sure this is
used by hyde park in Wallach has taken
one as well which is obviously my
inspiration for this ride I mean
sometime oh not enough cash well that's
not really an issue for me just gonna
get more of that how much long can I get
again Oh what that is plenty of money
that's much more than I could ever spend
and so what is how i paint in here I
really feel like this is an often
overlooked thing it's also really easy
and nice to make your general Park look
a lot better with new ground textures
and that's something which many people
don't do and it could definitely be
helpful in very well various scenarios
and there's also this roof text you from
loopy landscapes or coach crew follies
which you can actually use to make
buildings in this game but I'm not
really going to do that not too fun of
those things might do it at a later
stage but definitely not for this ride
this one is just going to have that kind
of mining theme to it obviously because
it's a mind train oh it would seriously
be a crime to not theme am I trained him
to mind that would be terrible seriously
now I need to see what kind of city me I
have yeah I don't have anything yet that
is an issue and what why why I put my
research and I put my research into
scenery to get this mine see me and what
does it give me jumping fountains like
what what am I supposed to do with that
like please next thing is going to be
the hedge maze I don't even have any
scenery or themI like jumping fountains
are the only thing in this entire thing
and now i'm getting the hedge maze oh
wow this is terrible well I'm gonna have
to find a solution to that can I have to
make this thing look like a mind without
actually being able to place anything
mine related yeah that's probably not
going to work all that well anyway I'm
just gonna work on whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa don't do that okay thank you it's
kind of funny how you can't remove these
fences if you click on like the mesh
area you really have to click on the
pole itself um yeah could I Q over here
is that too much no I'm just going to do
it kind of a long queue but no I I don't
really have anything else to fit in this
area it's just do small to place
anything and I'm not going to build a
path entirely around it although now
that wouldn't make too much sense um i'm
going to try something else though this
is going to be the exit part of a right
that i'm going to place over here I
don't know if I have any unplaced right
yeah I think I've already placed
everything yeah okay that is definitely
an issue I'm going to Oh already maximum
funding well I'm going to do that and a
later stage then and just play some
fences and I suppose some bushes and
just general ground shrubbery to kind of
like this kind of make this look more
awesome than it does now there's the
hedge maze which is something that
nobody wants or needs seriously and can
I like to play some bigger trees over
here I suppose that's okay oh why why
what is that even possible okay so how
good is this ryan actually well I can
ask 274 it it's not too bad for a right
this size and i think i'm going to open
it because you know it's already on and
running and the scenery is not finished
yet but I can make some money off of
this already it's called roller coaster
one which is not really the best name
I've ever seen some I can't come up with
anything let's just go for the most
generic name ever it's not about the
naming of rides it's about the passion
of the scenery and all that yeah the
thing is going to have to leave as soon
as another train enters the station
because otherwise it's going to hang
over there it's kind of awkward and I
know that technically in the game
nothing can go wrong over there but I
wouldn't like to hang over there too you
know I'm not going to do that and I
don't really know what kind of seen me I
want to put in this place maybe I could
put a fountain over here I don't know it
would be cool but it looks stupid II
and yeah that's nothing else I can
really place over here no real small
tree that wouldn't look awkward although
this looks okay I have to say this looks
pretty good you know the ride is not all
that bad I mean it's still somewhat it's
the locust somewhat mine related even
though there's no mining cinema and
people are already riding it that's like
a nearly full train nice not getting
anything over here yeah and I'm not even
going to place the hedge maze no no no
definitely not I'm just gonna place
benches and stuff like that and because
I got these fountains and put so much
research into them i'm going to place
them anyway torture the guests with
chinese water torture
he yeah they're enjoying it so that's
good what are what are the thoughts on
it it was great well that's good
everyone's unanimous it's an amazing
ride so great and we should move on i
think i should i should actually play
some more event that ventures what
fences over here you know i always liked
the fountains as a kid but now that I'm
looking at it I really don't understand
why it must be something with children
and liking being wet or something like
that because these things look
completely lame like that they're not
even good at aesthetically that little
blue pimples that they kind of look like
hmm well I put my money into them so
might as well and some of these
beautiful weeping willows because
they're absolutely gorgeous seriously
and I don't no one else i have my place
Peter do I have that yet oh I already ah
that's a shame um there is the
information a thingy but I already have
that to somebody is mowing the grass
that is that is a problem that is a huge
problem stop that right now what why do
I always forget about that um yeah maybe
it is time for some campaigning because
people have set that and I always forget
about this but now that I'm thinking
about it I should probably just an
campaign this entire bike and three
rides in a particular ride and like to
do that because their campaign costs
money too I don't know about this maybe
a half price entrance to the park would
be good because you know i think the
pike is already free so this is going to
trick people into our weekend we can go
to this point for a whole surprise but
guess what it's already free so whatever
people are going to go to my park and
that's good
still don't have anything to place over
here though we could dub we could
actually place a boat hire yeah these
are not really the best things out there
but no it's something the issue arises
with a Q though because fun quite hard
it's actually placing good cue with
these things the entrance is going to be
over here which is which is not handy I
know that as a terrible decision but I'm
gonna have a queue at least so I'm gonna
just try this I'm gonna at this it's
gonna be like a little pee or something
I have no idea what this actually is I'm
sorry I just want to have a small Q even
though this is a boat ride i'm probably
not going to be all that popular anyway
i definitely want to have the ability to
cure people okay decent could be better
but wait no no no no no no can we see
firm Oh only rowing boats oh well as a
kid I always thought that rowing boats
were terrible and not fun at all but
it's actually quite fun and I would
seriously I I would seriously consider
going on a rowing boat if I were in a
theme park and I just had some time to
spare of course I wouldn't go on a
rowing boat instead of going on this
little roller coaster something like
that but you know it would still be fun
it's not that bad actually now what is
this a single real roller coaster that
that is not the type of roller coaster
though I needed it needed i think i
forgot i already have plenty of roller
coasters in this bike in terms of roller
coasters that i can place but two roller
coasters two one two three four five
flat rides panting this thing as a flat
wide which is almost giving too much
credit to it um might seem like a bit
too much already but you know what I'm
just going to play some roller coasters
because I have nothing else to place
so the main area that I'm going to want
to expand upon is this area because it's
one big flat blob in leafy lake park
that has always hurt my eyes and I
definitely want to kind of fill up but
then again it's so far away from the
park entrance and guests in roller
coaster tycoon through your incredibly
dumb and they don't know how to navigate
but that doesn't matter I'm going to do
this anyway um let's see I'm gonna put a
station over here can i buy their land
next to this yeah because something's
bothering me about that little strip of
land everything okay good sorry that was
just my OCD trying to buy that because I
would have a straight line beautiful
straight line and lift Hill this coaster
is going to be way too expensive and way
too big but I don't care i win something
expensive and big although that doesn't
really work out too well mmhmm yeah
that's the single real roller coaster
which is one of the most useless things
ever and I can remember that was
actually a single real roller coaster in
one of my parks one of my favorite parts
i mean which is katies world which is
known as light water valley in real life
park in britain which also has that kind
of a ride but it was removed just one or
two years after this game came out and
it was also built just one or two years
before this game came out so that was
actually a terrible ride as well and
then was this single real roller coaster
which was supposed to be built in
Belgium but it it was built by topple
Meyer which usually only built ski lifts
but they decided to build a roller
coaster and it completely failed and you
know those are the memories that I have
of single real roller coasters they
don't really seem to work too well ok so
now we here we get the standard double
loop kind of technique as you make
seriously this is an autumn boring and
done many many times but I still want to
try it because it just looks so good now
the issue that i already have over here
is which color scheme am I going to give
this thing I think I'm gonna make it
purple don't have anything purple in
this bike yet support is a bit hard but
yeah I'll just go with black I still
think that the supports in this game
look better than the supportive roller
coaster tycoon 3 and that's just a the
graphics of this game in general I mean
the graphics of roller coaster tycoon
aren't that great in terms of in terms
of technical stuff I mean they're
they're religious sprites very pixelated
sprites but it's not that it's not
really how good the graphics are but
just how nice they look because it's
just something so cute and just I don't
know how to describe it but it just it
just looks great ok and now we're going
through the loop probably not going to
go through the second loop but this
looks like a decent construction over
here doesn't look too great from over
here or over here from that matter but
you know sometimes you build a coaster
from a certain angle and then it turns
out to be a coaster that looks great
from that angle but terrible from any
other angle and that's what I always
have at least only know if money once
again and people are seriously queuing
up for the mind mania which is very nice
oh wait I forgot I didn't have enough
cash for that well I can loan up to
fifty thousand euros i think so that's
going to be fine and now we get the the
ending part now this is very handy about
having a station at that height because
you know i think i can go down much more
than the height of the station so that
means that you can build up some speed
some speed but at the end when you go to
the station you don't have to lose a lot
of speed and that's just very handy
ah that really like being that close to
the station though but you know what I'm
just going to try it for once see how it
looks that's 14 hi might actually be a
bit high in a bit slow in the end so I'm
going to change that I'm going to make
that 13 and i'll probably make every
hill after this 13 as well though that
is also bit small isn't it hmm yeah this
is this is tough and I suppose that's
the one issue with placing your station
on a high platform like that well in
that case I'm just going to make that 14
suppose no real changes here now well
whatever ok so I'm going to go down over
here and do some fun stuff over here and
then call it a day that is if the
terraforming allows me to because
there's always this kind of a hill or a
tree or whatever in the way and I
suppose that's one negative aspect of
roller coaster tycoon one when you're
compared to the others it doesn't have
that handy kind of terraforming smart
terraforming system which automatically
removes terrain and stuff like that
this might actually be the break area it
would be a big break area though yeah i
feel like i would add something more to
this question is what mmm yeah it's hard
I I kind of want to wrap around the
track that I have right now but there's
really barely any space to do anything
over here so it might not be possible to
do anything and then there's a tree
among other things and I know can I do
this oh but that that is that is sexy
holy [ __ ] oh that is beautiful that's
Wow noise if there is this ride is
actually going to work out in terms of
speed and all that I'm going to be very
happy ok let's see station is going to
start over there long station is a good
station I'm going to place the entrance
and the exit that's a terrible place
whatever I just want to test the right
and once rain is not going to do never
ever so two trains for bracelets and
let's run ok so do I have anything else
yet well the haunted house is going to
do fine yeah definitely you know what I
actually do like a look of the ride from
this perspective too but it's still the
best from over here but in all aspects
it's great for my own
and I'm definitely going to change the
color scheme on the trains and I might
actually use six cars because even
though it's less efficient I just like
the look of six cars more because it
right now these things just look like
snakes in level 27 something like that
so that's not really the best thing but
definitely a great speed really like the
second part of the layout and into the
brakes now those riders going to be very
safe we're going to have no strata less
complaining about no brakes before the
station we're going to have Rob lv
complaining about brakes but whatever
think it's a good ride don't really know
what to call it yet but just going to
look at the statistics and see if this
is going to work out well seems that we
do need more handyman though she's gonna
get this guy you need to flip you need
to climb up and let's see those are some
great statistics yup definitely could
still benefit from some more paths
interaction and scenery and it might
actually be a bit higher if I can get it
about 65 that would be amazing but still
I like the ride overall so I'm really
happy about this but yeah that's it for
this episode so I'm thanks for watching
and I'll see you in the next one in
which I'm going to work more about on
this area and probably play play some
mom I suppose haunted houses and stuff
like that so till then